pour moi le gouvernement ne peut pas se
contenter d'observer de l'extérieur ce
qui se passe en guyane il ya des
ministres il ya un ministre de
l'outre-mer au moins il ya d'autres
ministres qui sont en situation de
responsabilité
leur place est sur le terrain et l'idée
que on attend que ça se décante que ça
bouge
cette idée là n'est pas la bonne je veux
rappeler que dans des circonstances
semblables il ya 20 ans j'étais ministre
de l'éducation les les étudiants les
enseignants une très grande partie de la
guyane est étant en mouvement en
ébullition il y avait des barricades
j'ai pris un avion je suis parti et les
décisions nécessaires ont été prises et
ce à régler la question est donc pour
moi et c'est d'ailleurs un souvenir
intéressant précieux que je partage avec
les avec les guyanais puisque ça a été
la décision de création du rectorat de
la guyane est donc pour moi il est
nécessaire il est indispensable que le
gouvernement prenne ses responsabilités
il est là pour ça
si vous avez des ministres si vous avez
un gouvernement c'est pour ne pas
laisser les situation se dégrader est-ce
que vous même vous comprenez la colère
des guyanais aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
soutenez leur mouvement en tout cas je
comprends n'est ce pas qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce qui est frappant pour les
guyanais et en guyane
d'abord un décalage immense entre la
plateforme spatiale la plus haute
technologie
évidemment un univers clos protéger et
puis le reste de la guyane qui est en
retard de développement
il n'y a pas de régions en france où le
manque d'écoles souhaite aussi cruel
qu'il est ennuyeux que j'allais vous
dire ya de nouveau des revendications à
la matière aujourd'hui à juste titre
qu'est ce que ça coûte de construire des
écoles n'y a pas besoin de chauffage en
guyana donc c'est tout à fait plausible
de réviser man 2 encore être sauvé ce
département peut encore être poussé vers
son développement et pas forcément celle
ouvrant le robinet à subventions
publiques
il suffit d'avoir des esprits pratiquer
des politiques qu'ils soient des
décisions fortes
d'accord